la fiducia si fa
quello che abbiamo capito oggi e che
senz'altro fiducia è uno degli elementi
chiave
inclusione e la fiducia è una delle
prime cose che impariamo nelle impariamo
dai nostri genitori da impariamo dai
grandi
impariamo a dargli la mano impariamo ad
affidarci con il primo gesto con cui
diamo la mano ma non solo la stretta di
mano rimane per tutta la nostra vita
come la fiducia rimane un tullo uno
strumento che utilizziamo un sacco di
volte anche nella nostra vita lavorativa
nella vita economica stringiamo la mano
concludiamo un accordo ci fidiamo
la stretta di mano ha però una
caratteristica che si svolge in un
momento c'è un contesto ci sono due
persone che si fidano l'una dell'altra
ma non solo fidarsi di un'altra persona
fiducia se anche rispetto ai contenuti
provate a immaginare di non fidarvi mai
di niente di fare sempre il double cech
su qualsiasi cosa è andare a sempre
verificare ogni singola fonte
ecco ci sono articoli scientifici che
dimostrano che impazziremo è
assolutamente impossibile ognuno di noi
si deve fidare di qualcosa dobbiamo solo
decidere di cosa a fidarci e quali sono
le informazioni che reputiamo più
importanti quale i task a cui devi
dedicare più tempo e quali invece quelli
a cui affidarsi
ecco qua arriva al punto con la
tecnologia e con tutte le nuove
opportunità che abbiamo nel mondo il
nostro campo di azione si è ampliato
tantissimo
non siamo più legati a un'area che
possiamo controllare siamo legati al
mondo la globalizzazione i mezzi
informatici ci permettono qualsiasi cosa
mandiamo un esempio concreto di oggi
sono venuta in treno a novara
ho comprato un treno online ci ho
comprato un biglietto non un treno
comprato un biglietto con un'app sul
cellulare
ecco qua comprato un biglietto con
un'app sul cellulare con questo
biglietto
io mi sono fidata che la compagnia mi
avesse dato un posto che quel posto
fosse solo mio che non ci fosse seduto
nessuno e che nessun altro lo avesse
comprato o che quel posto esistesse su
quel treno mi fidavo che c'era quella
carrozza eccetera eccetera
questo è così perché nella peggiore
delle ipotesi so che c'è
trenitalia all agenzia di turno che mi
rimborserà la spesa del biglietto so che
la peggiore delle ipotesi è che farò un
viaggio un po scomodo magari sarò seduto
nel corridoio oppure dovrò contrattare
dovrò trovare un altro posto
ma pensate se invece dovessimo andare a
ricontrollare ogni singolo biglietto
venduto dall'applicazione cioè sarebbe
uno sforzo talmente grande da non valere
il prezzo del biglietto nemmeno in
termini proprio di tempo quello che è
interessante della tecnologia che ci
permette oggi di fare questo passo fuori
dal fidarci per forza perché li ho visti
un po di sorrisetti e è vero che ci
fidiamo che ci dia una garanzia che ci
sia qualcuno che ci dà una garanzia ma
su cosa proprio ci fidiamo proprio su
tutto siamo disposti a delegare
qualsiasi cosa
c'è un detto famosissimo che dice
fidarsi è bene non fidarsi è meglio
e che cosa se la tecnologia ci
permettesse in un certo senso di fidarci
un pochino di meno lo sta già facendo
nel senso che sono sempre di più le
persone che condividono informazioni sui
social network fidandosi del titolo del
link peccato che in quel caso la
tecnologia soltanto lo strumento di
condivisione non uno strumento che mi
certifica la fiducia
io mi fido della fonte lo strumento non
mi certifica che la fonte sia quella che
io penso di citare né che il contenuto
sia veramente veritiero qua
arriva una delle tecnologie più
complicate e più discusse dell'ultimo
anno
glock chain sono grandemente
appassionata di blog chain non solo
perché studiando giurisprudenza essendo
appassionata di crittografia mi
piacciono solo le cose noiose ma anche
proprio per il suo aspetto più sociale
perché sempre più importante parlarne e
proprio per questo motivo
proverò a disegnare una ricetta facile
di che cos'è block chain sarà la parte
un pochino più complessa del talk ma vi
assicuro che scorrerà via liscio
e quindi cerchiamo di disegnare blocking
come la ricetta tra un database
distribuito e la crittografia
partiamo a spiegare una base di
crittografia quindi sa che cosa è utile
la crittografia se se io in questo
momento volessi dare un foglio di carta
a qualcuno in questa sala ma non
potessimo trovarci nello stesso posto
quindi non potessi stringergli la mano
dandogli il foglio il modo più sicuro
per non fidarmi di nessuno qua dentro a
darglielo sarebbe affittare una stanza
avere una chiave mettere il foglio nella
stanza e dare la chiave a qualcun'altra
la persona qui e voglio dare il foglio
eco benissimo se vuoi quel foglio userai
questa chiave entrerà in quella stanza e
prenderà il foglio fila tutto liscio
questa è la crittografia asimmetrica a
chiave simmetrica ma se io invece
volesse essere cioè la persona che
riceverà nel foglio dicesse io però
voglio essere proprio sicuro che sia tu
a darmi il foglio la cosa farei
avrei una stanza in cui solo io ho una
chiave d'ingresso che è la mia chiave
privata e da una chiave d'uscita a tutte
le persone che voglio che possano
prendere cose da quella stanza quindi un
giorno devo dare un foglio una persona
un giorno dopo devo dare un foglio
un'altra persona da una chiave più
persone e di cose voi entrata in quella
stanza in quella stanza ai fogli possono
essere solo da me
e anche in questo caso la persona entra
prende il foglio ed esce
aggiungiamo un altro livello di
complessità io voglio per essere sicura
che soltanto proprio quella persona
possa prendere il foglio
ora quel punto mi sarà sufficiente
mettere quel foglio nella mia stanza con
lo stesso meccanismo di prima ma anche
all'interno di una scatola chiusa con un
lucchetto che solo la persona che mi ha
dato la sua chiavetta potrà aprire a
quel punto una specie di matrioska in
questa matrioska io sono sicura che solo
io potrò dare quelle informazioni è solo
quella determinata persona potrà
riceverla questo è il primo elemento di
blog chain quindi crittografia abbiamo
questo sistema
associato a un'architettura
un'architettura di database tributi che
essenzialmente non sono né centralizzati
né decentralizzati ma pensi distribuiti
un'architettura centralizzata e
caratterizzata dal fatto che
un'informazione sta tutta in un punto e
tutte le macchine che sono interessate a
quella informazione la richiederanno a
quello determinato server le
decentralizzate sono caratterizzate dal
fatto che le stesse informazioni sono su
più punti diversi
le distribuite dal fatto che come ben
capirete
le informazioni sono su tutti le
macchine connesse una determinata rete
quindi per renderla un pochino più
visuale nel momento in cui immaginiamoci
un informazione viene modificata su un
server o non diventa più disponibile in
un distribuito questo non succede ma in
un centralizzato immaginiamo
un'informazione venga modificato non sei
più disponibile a quel punto tutte le
macchine connesse a questa è vero
avranno un informazione differente
quindi riceveranno un informazione
modificata in una connessione peer to
peer invece se la scatoletta blu dovesse
essere distribuita al computer grigio
questo potrà chiederlo direttamente al
computer o alla macchina che in quel
momento a quelli informazione
trasferendo quell'informazione
attraverso un canale peer to peer pari a
pari se un'altra macchina dovesse essere
interessata a quella medesima
informazione potrà semplicemente
richiederla o al primo o al secondo in
un unico a misura perché entrambi hanno
la stessa informazione se ora pensiamo a
blob chain unendo questa idea
dell'informazione su tutte le architette
le macchine e la possibilità di
verificare chi ha fatto che cosa abbiamo
la base di un sistema che ci permette di
determinare di avere tutti la conoscenza
di quello che fanno tutti è di quindi di
avere in un certo modo come prossimo in
tasca un piccolo registro di tutte le
transazioni ma anche allo stesso tempo
di conoscere in tempo reale quali sono
le modificazioni quindi le nostre
macchine automaticamente si aggiornano e
mantengono traccia l'esempio più comune
di blocks in quello che dico tutti
avrete sicuramente sentito parlare è
bitcoin quindi perché vi fidate di una
moneta e spero che nessuno di voi si
fidi di questo ok questo è veramente 30
euro perché riconoscete che non è vero
un 30 euro perché non ne primo non
esistono 30 euro no secondo perché
probabilmente a prenderlo in mano avrà
una sensazione al tatto differente
perché le filigrane non sono quelle
adatte i colori ci sono tutti degli
elementi fisici che in prossimità ci
dicono guarda questa non è una banconota
altrimenti sul digitale ci fidiamo di
entità che ci dicono guarda che quella
moneta quella transazione è avvenuta
perché io ti faccio da garante sto in
mezzo ma se io non volessi niente di
tutto questo
quelle pitkin bitcoin è essenzialmente
il modo in cui abbiamo trovato il modo
che abbiamo trovato di passarci una
banconota online
essendo sicuri che non venga spesa due
volte
quindi è come se voi aveste in mano
questa banconota da 100 euro e per darlo
a qualcuno dovesse firmarsi sopra e
avesse in tasca un registro che si
aggiorna automaticamente con tutte le
persone che detengono una banconota da
100 euro e quindi nel passaggio da una
persona all'altra quel libretto venisse
modificato e tu potessi accettare quella
banconota se sul tuo libretto risulta
che è veramente quello il codice da cui
deve venire e allo stesso tempo anche
altre persone identificate con un con un
sistema di consenso potessero verificare
che quella è veramente così ok faccio
mio pentimento anch'io tutta la rete
deve aggiornare che adesso quella
banconota non è più mio è tuo
ovviamente su un blog ci basto
semplificando non ci sono i nomi delle
persone
ci sono dei codici dei codici legati
alla crittografia
ma è solo per darvi un'idea che non è
vero che bitcoin sia genericamente
anonimo
e non identificato ma potenzialmente
identificabile
dipende tutto dall'utilizzo che se ne fa
un'altra applicazione interessantissima
di blogchess sono gli smart contract che
essenzialmente vuol dire una volta che
la moneta e software o che qualsiasi
operazione tracciabile software allora
possiamo aggiungerci delle cose quindi
quel pagamento può avvenire soltanto una
determinata condizione ci sono casi nel
diritto romano fin dalle origini di se
la nave verrà dall'asia
allora ti pagherò questo può essere
codificato questo succede tutti i giorni
nelle nostre macchine e questo potrebbe
dare grandi accessi alla giustizia
perché non c'è più spazio
all'inadempimento all'ingiustizia se
prima si arriva a scrivere un contratto
con le regole rigorose di un software e
questa per me inclusione inclusione
anche la possibilità di potersi fidare
di non avere paura di dare una propria
informazione ma anche di poter
controllare di essere se stessi di
sentirsi civicamente inclusi all'interno
di un meccanismo di controllo il
registro non sta più da qualche parte
polverosa che non lo so devo controllare
il registro può essere sulla mia
macchina
io posso controllarlo potenzialmente ci
sono casi di studio sul catasto potrà
avere il catasto sulla mia macchina
perché devo lasciarlo da qualche parte
posso verificarlo una informazione mia
un'informazione collettiva pubblica
ci sono diversi casi studio
sull'identità anche le identità
transazionali in cui quindi ognuno
potrebbe identificarsi senza aver
bisogno di un'autorità centrale che
potrebbe anche quindi ritirare il
passaporto o un passaporto che potrebbe
perdersi tanti sono i casi purtroppo di
persone che si trovano a perdere la
propria identità proprio perché perdono
un documento fisico cartacea nel mondo
di oggi non può più essere così ho anche
nel mondo ovviamente delle ng
quante volte ci siamo chiesti come
abbiamo fatto un impatto
quante volte ci siamo chiesti se
davvero quello che abbiamo donato è
arrivato il destinatario
sarebbe molto bello poter aiutare tutte
quelle organizzazioni a non avere più il
problema di doverlo verificare
attraverso un sistema che tagliavia
tutta la corruzione kiedis intermedia
riusciamo in questo modo a non avere più
bisogno di garanti in mezzo nelle nostre
i nostri processi garanti che sono stati
utilissimi nella nostra vita sociale ma
che non lo sono più perché possiamo
forse fidarci della tecnologia averla
nelle nostre mani poter controllare
ognuno di noi da ovunque le informazioni
e quindi come vi dicevo anche avere un
accesso alla giustizia che sia diverso
una giustizia informatica che non vuol
dire che ci debba per forza essere un
grande cervello molto più intelligente
di noi che prende una decisione ma
semplicemente che possiamo eseguire con
la semplicità con cui eseguiamo
quotidianamente tasche sui nostri
computer possiamo dare anche a
attuazione a quello che abbiamo deciso
con le altre persone e questa è una
conversazione che si deve avere oggi
perché è vero che blog cin non è ancora
diffusa è vero che ancora solo per gli
addetti ai lavori è vero che anche noi è
difficile da capire però è anche vero
che succederà in un batter di ciglia e
che forse sarebbe bene anzi sono sicura
sarebbe bene tutti avessero gli
strumenti per partecipare a una delle
rivoluzioni più belle e più sociali a
cui assisteremo nei prossimi anni e
quindi con questo vi lascio sarebbe
sempre più bello sentirci inclusi anche
noi nel nostro futuro
grazie
[Applauso]